Xin chào tôi tên là Emma, một video trong ngày hôm nay tôi
sẽ dạy cho bạn một số biểu thức chính.
Bạn có thể sử dụng khi ai đó nói với bạn điều gì đó không đúng
đúng và bạn muốn tranh luận với những gì họ đang nói.
Vì vậy, trong video này tôi sẽ dạy cho bạn những biểu cảm tuyệt vời này.
Nhưng trước khi tôi làm điều đó.
Chúng ta sẽ nói về 3 từ rất phổ biến trong tiếng Anh.
Những ngày này, 3 từ đó là những lý thuyết âm mưu tin tức giả
và trò lừa bịp là vậy trong video này bạn sẽ học
những từ này có nghĩa là gì?
Và bạn cũng sẽ học được những gì để nói với ai đó
điều đó cho bạn biết điều gì đó không đúng.
Được rồi, hãy bắt đầu nào.
Vậy tôi có 3 câu là câu đầu tiên
là các nhà khoa học nói Trái đất phẳng,
không tròn. Điều này đúng hay không đúng?
OK, câu này không đúng, một số người tin điều này
nhưng nó không đúng.
Câu thứ hai của tôi Michael Jackson vẫn sống và sống như
Kim Kardashian.
Đúng hay không đúng.
Một lần nữa, chúng tôi có một câu không đúng Tôi
đã làm điều này lên.
Và cuối cùng, câu thứ ba của tôi nghe nhạc rock gây ra
ung thư là điều này đúng hay không đúng.
Một lần nữa, điều này là không đúng sự thật. Tôi cũng đã làm điều này vì vậy
quan điểm của tôi ở đây là rất nhiều điều bạn
nghe từ những người trong cuộc trò chuyện là không đúng sự thật.
Mọi người nói, những loại điều này mọi lúc và
bạn sẽ biết rằng đây là điều không đúng
Vậy bạn sẽ nói gì khi ai đó nói với bạn rằng
trái đất phẳng hoặc họ nói bạn rằng Michael
Jackson đang sống như Kim Kardashian,
vì vậy tôi sẽ dạy cho bạn những biểu cảm tuyệt vời mà bạn có thể
sử dụng.
Trước khi tôi làm điều đó tôi chỉ muốn nói rằng
3 câu này cũng có thể được coi là tin giả.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ xem xét ý nghĩa của tin tức giả
trong giây lát.
OK vậy 3 từ chính,
Tôi muốn dạy bạn hôm nay là những từ mà bạn
sẽ thấy rất nhiều trên Internet và trên phương tiện
.
Từ đầu tiên là tin giả Vậy tin giả là gì
tin trong khi giả có nghĩa là không đúng?
Tin tức giả là những câu chuyện tin tức không có thật và
chúng được tạo ra để gây thiệt hại cho một người,
một doanh nghiệp. Một cơ quan hoặc chính phủ hoặc họ cũng có thể
được tạo ra để thu hút sự chú ý và nhận được nhấp chuột vào
Internet.
Vì vậy, bạn sẽ thấy rất nhiều tin tức giả trên các phương tiện truyền thông xã hội khác nhau như Twitter,
Facebook và rất nhiều nơi khác để trực tuyến.
Vì vậy, đây là từ rất phổ biến ngày nay rất nhiều
mọi người đang sử dụng nó.
Vì vậy, điều quan trọng là bạn biết ý nghĩa của nó.
Chúng tôi cũng có từ ở đây,
thuyết âm mưu. Vì vậy, một thuyết âm mưu.
là một lời giải thích? Về một sự kiện hoặc tình huống khác với
khác với tài khoản chính thức của âm mưu Times ~ các lý thuyết về chính phủ hoặc một doanh nghiệp làm điều gì đó bất hợp pháp
hoặc làm hại ai đó vì vậy hãy nghĩ về một số âm mưu
.
Một số người tin rằng hạ cánh mặt trăng.
Vì vậy, khi các phi hành gia lên mặt trăng vào những năm
1960.
Một số người tin rằng hạ cánh mặt trăng là giả.
Đây là một thuyết âm mưu phổ biến.
Một lý thuyết âm mưu khác, tôi đã nghe gần đây là một số người tin rằng
rằng Paul McCartney từ The Beatles thực sự đã chết vào năm 1966
và có một người đàn ông khác đã thay thế anh ta và
người thực sự là nhạc sĩ giỏi hơn đây là một lý thuyết âm mưu khác nhau
.
Vì vậy, bạn sẽ thấy rất nhiều thuyết âm mưu trên Internet
Và rất nhiều người sẽ cho bạn biết lý thuyết âm mưu
trong các cuộc trò chuyện.
Từ cuối cùng tôi muốn dạy cho bạn là trò lừa bịp
.
Hoax nên một trò lừa bịp. Là một loại trò đùa thực tế
có nghĩa là làm xấu hổ hoặc làm tổn thương mọi người nên một số ví dụ
của trò lừa bịp?
Có phải chúng ta sẽ có những trò lừa bịp này không chụp ảnh
của người ngoài hành tinh hoặc quái vật và nói với mọi người xem.
Chúng tôi có bằng chứng về quái vật hoặc người ngoài hành tinh này,
nhưng nếu nó không đúng thì nó.
Đó là một trò đùa của trò đùa thực tế.
Vì vậy, một lần nữa giả thuyết âm mưu tin tức giả là một trò lừa bịp
rất phổ biến trên Internet và vì vậy đối với những điều này
điều đó không đúng?
Bạn nói gì với mọi người khi họ nói với bạn
thông tin không đúng sự thật này?
Vâng, hãy tìm hiểu ngay.
OK, vì vậy bạn đã nghe một câu chuyện tin tức giả hoặc âm mưu
lý thuyết hoặc một trò lừa bịp.
Có lẽ dì hoặc bạn của bạn vừa nói với bạn điều đó
một bạn biết điều đó không đúng. Vậy bạn
nói gì với họ?
Chà, những gì bạn có thể làm là bạn có thể thách thức đối số
của họ không?
Vì vậy, ví dụ, bạn có thể nói.
Vì vậy, hãy để tôi nói thẳng điều này bạn đang nói và bạn
có thể lặp lại những gì họ nói.
Vì vậy, hãy để tôi nói thẳng rằng bạn đang nói Paul McCartney
chết năm 1966.
Và sau đó, những gì bạn có thể nói là.
Và nói rằng điều đó không đúng.
Điều đó không chính xác. Tôi thấy khó tin.
Điều đó không có ý nghĩa. Vì vậy, đây là tất cả các biểu thức,
chúng tôi sử dụng khi chúng tôi nói rằng tôi không tin bạn.
Bây giờ, nếu chúng ta muốn nói điều gì đó là
một chút bất lịch sự hơn.
Chúng ta có thể sử dụng từ BS như trong BS đó.
BS là viết tắt của nhảm nhí, đôi khi chúng tôi không muốn
thề vì vậy chúng tôi có thể nói với bạn bè của mình đó là
tổng số BS hoặc đó là BS.
Bạn cũng có thể nói với ai đó thật lố bịch,
có nghĩa đó là một câu chuyện ngu ngốc.
Điều đó thật nực cười, điều đó không đúng.
Vì vậy, đây là tất cả các ví dụ về những điều phổ biến.
Mọi người nói khi ai đó nói với họ điều gì đó mà họ không
hãy tin vì vậy bây giờ chúng ta hãy xem một số điều khác chúng ta
có thể nói khi ai đó kể cho chúng ta một câu chuyện tin tức giả.
OK, vậy một điều khác bạn có thể làm khi ai đó nói
bạn tin tức giả hoặc điều gì đó không đúng sự thật là bạn
có thể hỏi họ nguồn của họ ở đâu hoặc họ đã lấy thông tin từ đâu? Vì vậy, đây là câu hỏi lớn
khi chúng ta nói về các nguồn hoặc các nguồn mới
nói về người đã nói như vậy chẳng hạn,
có lẽ tin tức đến từ mẹ của bạn.
Vì vậy, có lẽ đó không phải là một nguồn tuyệt vời.
Có lẽ nó đến từ BBC News.
Hoặc có thể nó đến từ wika pedia hoặc Facebook hoặc
nếu bạn trong khoa học thì có lẽ nó đến từ một
Tạp chí được đánh giá ngang hàng.
Có lẽ nó đến từ Twitter hoặc dì của bạn hoặc bạn bè của bạn
vì vậy thật tốt khi hỏi ai đó.
Họ lấy thông tin từ đâu?
Và sau đó bạn có thể nghĩ về OK đó là một nguồn tốt
.
Và rất nhiều lần nó có thể không.
Và bạn có thể nói với họ điều này OK,
vì vậy nếu ai đó nói với bạn chẳng hạn,
rằng cuộc đổ bộ mặt trăng đã không xảy ra và có một âm mưu lớn
và người ngoài hành tinh kiểm soát Mỹ và Canada và Trung Quốc
nhưng bạn có thể nói với họ là ai đã nói với bạn
đó? Nguồn tin tức của bạn ở đâu và nếu họ nói,
Oh, bạn của tôi Gary đã nói với tôi điều đó thì bạn
có thể nói đó không phải là một nguồn tin tốt.
Bạn cũng có thể hỏi họ tại sao hoặc làm thế nào câu hỏi vậy
chẳng hạn,
bạn biết tại sao không. Bạn biết.
Hãy bắt đầu với làm thế nào. Làm thế nào chính phủ sẽ bảo vệ điều đó
hoặc làm thế nào nhạc rock and roll gây ung thư
để bạn luôn có thể hỏi những câu hỏi này?
Tại sao và làm thế nào bạn biết,
có lẽ họ có một lời giải thích tốt.
Nhưng thật tốt khi hỏi những câu hỏi này để tìm hiểu
thêm về lý do tại sao họ nghĩ những gì họ nghĩ.
Bạn cũng có thể phản bác lại ý nghĩa của việc họ nói nếu họ
nói điều gì đó,
và bạn không đồng ý bạn có thể nói ý kiến của mình như vậy cho ví dụ
.
Nếu ai đó nói với bạn rằng Kim Kardashian thực sự là Michael
Jackson.
Bạn có thể nói thực tế của vấn đề là Michael
Jackson đã qua đời.
Anh ấy không phải là Kim Kardashian.
Sự thật là Michael Jackson và Kim Kardashian hay không
cùng một người.
Bạn cũng có thể nói trong thực tế.
Trong thực tế, Michael Jackson không phải là Kim Kardashian.
Vì vậy, đây là những biểu hiện tuyệt vời,
bạn có thể sử dụng khi bạn đang cố nói với ai đó rằng
những gì họ nói là không chính xác và những gì bạn đang nói
là niềm tin chính xác.
OK vì vậy chúng tôi đã đi qua tất cả những điều khác nhau để
nói.
Khi ai đó nói với bạn điều gì đó không đúng, vì vậy hãy
thực hành nó.
OK, điều này chỉ trong câu chuyện tin tức giả.
Bạn có nghe thấy những kẻ khủng bố đã làm tan chảy Nam Cực bằng cách sử dụng tia laser
khổng lồ,
vì vậy những kẻ khủng bố đã làm tan chảy Nam Cực bằng cách sử dụng tia laser khổng lồ?
Vì vậy, đó là câu chuyện tin tức,
mà tôi vừa mới tạo nên.
Đó là tin giả. Vì vậy, nguồn của bạn là Emma.
Và đây không phải là một nguồn tốt cho tin tức này
câu chuyện.
Vậy bạn có thể nói gì với tôi nếu tôi đưa
cho bạn một câu chuyện giả mạo như thế?
Hoặc có thể bạn sẽ nói điều đó không đúng mà bạn có thể nói
Bạn đã nghe thấy Emma ở đâu?
Tại sao những kẻ khủng bố làm tan chảy Nam Cực bằng một tia laser khổng lồ?
Làm thế nào những kẻ khủng bố có được tia laser để bạn có thể hỏi
những câu hỏi này và sau đó bạn có thể nói cho tôi sự thật.
Thực tế của vấn đề là Arctica đã không
bị những kẻ khủng bố làm tan chảy đó là tin giả.
Vì vậy, cảm ơn bạn đã xem Tôi hy vọng bạn đã học được điều gì đó
có thể về một số từ này như trò lừa bịp tin tức giả
hoặc thuyết âm mưu.
Ngoài ra, có thể một số biểu thức bạn có thể sử dụng khi bạn nghe
một cái gì đó không đúng sự thật.
Tôi muốn mời bạn đến xem trang web
của chúng tôi tại WWW dotindeed.com.
Ở đó bạn thực sự có thể làm một bài kiểm tra để thực hành những gì
bạn học được trong video này.
Tôi cũng muốn mời bạn đăng ký
kênh của tôi. )
Cảm ơn bạn đã xem cho đến lần tiếp theo chăm sóc.